en el último video usamos Los criterios
de la aromaticidad para ver que los
heterociclos pueden ser aromáticos
también en este video vamos a ver más
heterociclos aromáticos específicamente
anillos de cinco miembros empezaremos
con el pirrol que está aquí abajo en la
molécula de pirrol como puedes ver hay
cinco átomos en el anillo y si
observamos los carbonos en el anillo
podemos ver que esos carbonos tienen un
doble enlace cada uno de ellos tiene
hibridación sp2 lo que significa que
cada carbono tiene un orbital p libre
puedo continuar dibujando un orbital p
libre en cada uno de esos cuatro
carbonos
así en términos del nitrógeno del anillo
Necesito saber el estado de hibridación
de este nitrógeno la mejor manera de
hacer eso es calcular el número estérico
sabemos que el número estérico es igual
al número de enlac sigma más el número
de pares libres de electrones puedo ver
que hay un enlace Sigma aquí hay un
enlace Sigma y aquí hay un enlace Sigma
Así que hay tres enlace Sigma más los
pares libres de electrones hay un par
libre de electrones en ese nitrógeno de
ahí por lo que el número estérico
Debería ser igual a 4 lo que significa
que el pirrol tiene un estado de
hibridación
sp3 Pero sabemos que ese no es el caso
porque el pirrol es una molécula
aromática un nitrógeno con hibridación
sp3 significaría que no hay orbitales p
en ese nitrógeno lo que violaría
el primer criterio para que este
compuesto sea aromático y entonces Debe
de haber alguna manera en la que podamos
hacer que ese nitrógeno tenga
hibridación
sp2 Y por supuesto vimos Cómo hacer eso
al final del último video este par libre
de electrones en ese nitrógeno De hecho
no está localizado en ese
nitrógeno podemos tomar este par de
electrones y moverlos acá por lo que Ese
par libre de electrones puede participar
en la resonancia si Ese par libre de
electrones Se movió ahí para hacer un
enlace pi eso mandaría a estos
electrones a este carbono por lo que la
estructura resonante tendrá el nitrógeno
con un enlace pi aquí ahora y hay un par
libre de electrones en este carbono lo
que le da una carga formal de -1 aún
tenemos un enlace pi aquí de esta manera
y este nitrógeno ahora tendrá una carga
formal de + 1 Ahora cuando analizamos el
Estado de hibridación de este nitrógeno
una vez más buscamos los enlaces Sigma
así que tenemos un enlace Sigma dos
enlaces Sigma y tres enlace Sigma tres
enlace Sigma esta vez no hay pares de
electrones porque ahora Ese par libre de
electrones está deslocalizado en la
resonancia Así que
3 + 0 es ig a
3 lo que significa que este nitrógeno
Ahora tiene hibridación
s2 ya que ese nitrógeno tiene
hibridación sp2 tiene un orbital p libre
Así que podemos continuar dibujando el
orbital p en ese nitrógeno Y entonces
puedes pensar puedes pensar en términos
de diagramas de puntos cierto estos dos
electrones de Aquí estos dos electrones
están de hecho deslocalizados y
participando en la resonancia Ese par
libre de
electrones puedes de hecho pensar en
ellos como si ocuparan un orbital p aquí
y De hecho están deslocalizados cierto
tenemos todos estos electrones pi
deslocalizados a lo largo de nuestro
anillo y ahora continuemos checando el
criterio para la aromaticidad el pirrol
sí contiene un anillo de orbitales p que
se traslapan continuamente y también
tiene 4n + 2 electrones pi en el
anillo continuemos resalt estándolo
tenemos estos electrones pi ahí son dos
estos electrones pi ya son cuatro y
estos electrones pi en magenta De hecho
están deslocalizados en el anillo lo que
nos da seis electrones pi Así que si n =
1 4 * 1 + 2 me da seis electrones pi el
pirrol tiene seis electrones pi también
tiene un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente por lo que
podemos decir que es
aromático continuemos con otra molécula
aquí similar al anterior este es
imidazol para el imidazol nuevamente
tenemos la misma historia o situación
que en el pirrol con este nitrógeno de
aquí primero pareciera que ese nitrógeno
tuviera hibridación
sp3 Pero podemos dibujar una estructura
resonante para él podemos tomar estos
electrones de aquí y moverlos acá lo que
mandaría estos electrones al nitrógeno
de
arriba continuamos dibujando la
estructura resonante para
eso tenemos algunos electrones pi un
doble enlace aquí ahora Tendremos una
carga formal de + un en este nitrógeno y
tendríamos una carga noral de -1 en este
nitrógeno de arriba
así nuevamente vemos que este nitrógeno
en azul tiene hibridación sp2 déjalo
resalto aquí en azul en la derecha este
nitrógeno De hecho tiene hibridación
sp2 es exactamente la misma situación
que tuvimos en el pirrol primero parecía
que esos electrones estaban localizados
en el nitrógeno pero esos electrones no
lo estaban esos electrones están
deslocalizados en el anillo por la
posible estructura resonante y hemos
determinado que ese nitrógeno en azul
unido a ese hidrógeno tiene hibridación
sp2 por aquí puedes identificar ese
nitrógeno en azul que está Unido al
hidrógeno tiene hibridación
sp2 por lo tanto tiene un orbital p
libre puedo continuar dibujando el
orbital p en ese
nitrógeno si veo a los carbonos si veo a
los carbonos en esta
molécula continuaré resaltando estos
carbonos en rojo Aquí estos tres
carbonos en mi diagrama de puntos
original podemos ver que tienen un doble
enlace todos tienen hibridación
sp2 Así que puedo continuar dibujando
los orbit tales p en esos carbonos
también y luego nuevamente si vuelvo al
diagrama de puntos original y esta vez
pongo atención al
nitrógeno continuaré dibujando este en
magenta este nitrógeno de aquí si veo
Este primer diagrama de puntos es igual
que el ejemplo de la piridina que vimos
en el video anterior de hecho tiene
hibridación sp2 y ya que tiene
hibridación sp2 podemos pensar en estos
electrones en
magenta como si participaran en la
resonancia y los electrones aquí de azul
como si estuvieran localizados en ese
átomo de nitrógeno localizados en un
orbital con hibridación
sp2 puedo continuar identificando este
nitrógeno en magenta de aquí solo digo
que este nitrógeno va en
magenta puedo decir decir que tiene
hibridación sp2 es exactamente la misma
situación de la piridina puedo continuar
dibujando un orbital p en él y Ese par
libre de electrones en azul que están en
ese nitrógeno Ese par libre de
electrones
ocupa continuaré poniéndolos en azul Ese
par libre de
electrones ocupará un orbital con
hibridación sp2 en el nitrógeno por lo
que esos electrones no están
participando en la resonancia esos
electrones están localizados en ese
nitrógeno Entonces cuando continuamos
pensando en Los criterios para la
aromaticidad nuestro primer criterio es
tener orbitales p que se traslapan
continuamente y puedo ver que ese es el
caso tenemos orbitales p traslapados
todos tienen hibridación sp2 en nuestro
anillo y por supuesto también
necesitamos 4 n + 2 electrones Pi y
entonces déjame continuar resaltando
esos en magenta mis electrones pi
volviendo a mi diagrama de puntos
original aquí hay dos aquí hay cuatro y
luego este par libre en nuestro
nitrógeno esos son de hecho esos son de
hecho electrones Pi y pensamos en esta
estructura resonante de
aquí continuaré resaltos en magenta
nuevamente hay de hecho seis electrones
pi en la molécula de
imidazol y esos electrones pi están
deslocalizados alrededor de este anillo
alrededor de estos orbitales p
traslapados Y entonces la molécula de
imidazol es aromática también la
molécula de imidazol es de hecho muy
importante en bioquímica veamos una
molécula muy famosa que con contiene el
anillo de imidazol y esta molécula se
llama
histamina cualquier persona que tenga
alergias Ha oído hablar de la histamina
y puedes ver el anillo de
imidazol aquí a la izquierda en la
molécula de histamina si quieres
entender bioquímica es muy útil entender
este concepto de la química orgánica la
histamina sería un ejemplo de un
heterociclo biológico aromático esta
porción de la molécula y el anillo de
imidazol es aromático satisface los dos
criterios como hemos visto hagamos un
ejemplo más de un heterociclo aromático
Aquí esta vez veamos un ejemplo que
contenga azufre esta molécula es llamada
tiofeno Esta es de hecho la molécula con
azufre análoga a la molécula de pirrol
empecemos analizando este azufre en
términos de su número estérico
pondré atención en este azufre de aquí y
calcular el número estérico de ese
azufre el número de enlace Sigma en ese
átomo y aquí hay un enlace Sigma aquí
hay un enlace
Sigma tenemos que el número
estérico es igual al número de enlace
Sigma más el número de pares libres de
electrones tenemos dos pares libres de
electrones alrededor de ese azufre así
Eso sería 2 + 2 lo que es igual a 4 Lo
que implica que ese azufre tiene
hibridación
sp3 Pero eso no funciona para nuestro
concepto de aromaticidad porque para que
algo sea aromático nuestro átomo debe de
tener hibridación sp2 para tener un
orbital p Libre como estos carbonos de
aquí una vez
más estos carbonos todos tienen un doble
enlace todos esos carbonos tienen un
orbital p puedo continuar
dibujando esos orbitales p en los
carbonos de esta manera
el azufre pareciera tener hibridación
sp3 por supuesto va a ser un caso
similar al de la molécula de pirrol
puedo mostrar una estructura resonante
para esta molécula de tiofeno puedo
tomar uno de estos pares libres de
electrones diré que es el par libre a la
derecha aquí y puedo mostrar el
movimiento para formar un enlace pi
entre el azufre y este carbono por
supuesto estos electrones se moverán a
este carbono Y entonces cuando continúo
dibujando esta estructura resonante
Ahora hay un enlace pi entre el azufre y
este carbono un par libre de electrones
Se movió a este carbono dándole una
carga formal de
-1 aún hay un enlace pi aquí y aún hay
un par libre de electrones en el azufre
ahora podemos también darle al azufre
una carga formal de
+1 y podemos analizarlo en términos de
su número
estérico nuevamente número de enlace
Sigma Este es un enlace Sigma Este es un
enlace Sigma por lo que el número
estérico será igual a 2 más Cuántos
pares libres de electrones Ahora solo
hay un
2 + 1 es ig a
3 ahora podemos ver que de hecho tiene
hibridación
sp2 tiene tres orbitales con hibridación
sp2 y uno de esos orbitales con
hibridación
sp2 contendrá Ese par libre de
electrones en azul de ahí Ese par libre
de
electrones
otra vez Tiene hibridación
sp2 tiene otros dos orbitales con
hibridación sp2 y esos orbitales
hibridados están formando enlaces con
esos carbonos de ahí ya que tienen
hibridación cp2 tienen un orbital p sin
hibridar puedo continuar dibujando ese
orbital p sin hibridar y puedo pensar en
uno de esos pares libres de electrones
en mi diagrama de puntos original
ocupando un orbital p Así que regresemos
al diagrama de puntos original del
tiofeno puedo pensar en uno de esos
pares libres de
electrones los Resaltar en magenta
ocupando un orbital p puedo continuar
dibujándolos ahí así y puedo pensar en
el otro par de electrones en ese
diagrama de puntos ocupando un orbital
con hibridación SP a un lado cuando veas
este tipo de situación piensa en dónde
están esos electrones pi realmente y
también Tengo estos electrones Pi y
estos electrones pi 2 4 seis tenemos un
total de seis electrones pi el cual es
un número de huel están de localizados a
lo largo de nuestro anillo a lo largo de
nuestros orbitales p la pados Y entonces
podemos decir finalmente que la molécula
de tiofeno es aromática ya que satisface
Los criterios Y por supuesto hay
análogos al tiofeno usando oxígeno y esa
por supuesto es una situación muy
similar y puedes dibujar otras
estructuras resonantes pero quise
dibujar este par para mostrar que uno de
esos pares libres está de hecho
deslocalizado y participando en la
resonancia
y otro par está localizado en el átomo
de azufre y localizado en un orbital con
hibridación
sp2 Así es como se analizan heterociclos
aromáticos